we turn to our political leaders for
guidance in times of crisis like the
scenes
the world witness at the capitol but
yesterday president trump did not
condemn the violence
and when he spoke about the people who
stormed the building he said this
we love you you're very special now this
comes amid new talk of potentially
invoking the 25th amendment to remove
the president from office
political correspondent ed o'keefe joins
us now to continue that conversation ed
really good to see you this morning i
want to pick up on the president's words
where he said you're special we love you
he practically said listen let's all go
meet at the capitol to sort of
really gin everybody up and he still has
not condemned their actions
this morning what does this ultimately
do to his presidency if anything at this
point
i think it's unforgettable and
unforgivable and if you thought that
what happened here in washington last
summer
outside the white house when they
cleared lafayette square so that he
could walk over and
hold a bible upside down outside of
church was bad
well this was you know even more
dramatic and unsettling and
scary and uh just a complete repudiation
of
of all that this country's built on and
i think you saw it in the very quick
and emotional reaction of republicans
who admit that they probably had put up
with this for far too long
and so i i think you know while
yesterday was interesting
and eventful and terrible and really
just heartbreaking
watch what happens today what kind of
leadership do we see today
from fellow republicans what actions
what actions might they take today
yeah that leads to my next question ed i
think you set it up
beautifully because now there's all
sorts of chatter about invoking the 25th
amendment that would take mike pence
that would take the cabinet
how likely is that to happen and how
serious do you think those conversations
really are well as our margaret brennan
was first to report last night they are
serious and that's why
we are even discussing it because it's
been talked about in an academic sense
or on cable news ad nauseam for four
years
but last night it was the most serious
it's ever been because the actual people
who would sign a paper
are now discussing it ask the question
again in 24 hours gail
and if we haven't seen movement today on
this issue
then it's probably going to fall victim
to the calendar only 13 days remain
and this would take a few days and
there's going to be a real conversation
if it's serious about do we want to put
the country through this over the next
few days or do we have no choice but to
do it
for fear that something worse could
happen yeah because if that happens he
cannot run again and a lot of people
are saying maybe that is a message that
needs to be sent i want to talk about
president-elect biden who came out and
spoke actually
before president trump who still really
hasn't addressed the nation
uh in a live in a live forum he released
that tweet as you know
but president biden president-elect
biden called on
uh president trump to stand up and he
called on the american people to stand
up too
what kind of challenges what kind of
challenges is present for his presidency
enormous challenges enormous enormous
we've never seen a president have to
deal with this before
but i hearken back to something one of
his senior aides told me yesterday
morning ahead of this
i asked how are you going to be able to
work with republicans this aide said
look
a bipartisan majority of democrats and
republicans stood up against this
we'll work with those people all right
ed thank you very much nice job you
noran major it was stellar from
beginning to end thank you so much